giúp độ lần quay gian, hăng trăm người trong đêm, măng loại đại đi đời nữ trong tiền.
Theo bỏ người lâu đồng, tôi nêm mẹ trám tạm mời,
hăng trăm người dân tập trung trước tân nhà của bà tế thế hát,
năm may bài tuổi, sống mình thành sát thương lòng,
quyền quyền quyền quyền yêu tình gian,
sát kinh a tin, đương dây tin sự đàn trên diện bàn bị vấn lợh,
được biết, bà hát, là một trong những người cầm đầu đường dây tin giúp tại sát thương lòng.
Để đời được tin, nhưng người dân măng loại tới trước cộng nhà bà hát,
phát nhạc đam mạc, hòa hết ở biến, tư nhiên không có kích qua sơ nhà bà hát đồng tý cộng,
không dừng lại đó, người dân tích tục kèo đến nhà của một đồng mối khác là bà bê tế nưu.
Năm mê sảo tuổi ở tôn cộng qua sát quyền lòng, tư nhiên,
tình trạm gứng tự tự như trên, theo người dân đương dây vi động bổ này,
là dông một nhóm người có họ hàng viên nhau tại độ quân cầm đầu.
Bà đồng, nhóm người này chả tin lại xuất rất lớn,
tà hôn nên hàn, nên dần người dân bất đậu tin tựng vị tiền.
Thống kê chưa đầy đủ, sấu tiền vi động cường người dân lên đến hàn chăm tý đồng.
Bởi, mọi những người khá sả thì có rất đồng những họ dân khó khăn cũng tình tựng thăm ra quyết tiền.